he is uh Big Papi who just joined us
here in the man cave as we sprinkle in a
little baseball here
South Beach our first guest today
single-handedly broke the curse of the
Bambino by leading the Red Sox to three
World Series titles well I don't know
about single-handedly he's the all-time
leader four home runs by designated
hitter which means he couldn't play the
field home runs that sounds like a lot
that's just the tip of the iceberg for
reasons this man will never ever have to
buy a drink in the city of Boston again
please welcome Big Papi right there all
right looking good first place in the
World Series I have no choice
did you ever play football did you ever
want to play football look man back in
the Dominican yeah back in my younger
days
poopa was only in sport that you only
were allowed to watch them on TV nothing
else now you had kids playing football
playing soccer different spore you know
but you know bass what is the pain down
there Plus basketball without a doubt
like that was that was my number one
it's poor with poor baseball how good
were you at basketball I was okay I was
okay you know I I move better back then
to what I do now were you soccer player
as well
so what soccer no soccer wasn't my thing
I became to be fan of soccer you know
past 10 years basically boy basketball
and baseball was the real deal diner
who was your favorite basketball player
growing up you know I definitely follow
Michael AJ yeah but you know it was
another player who definitely it was
when you watch him play you basically
was watching Michael Jordan
was my man breasts and please Kobe
Bryant did you get to meet Michael or
Kobe yeah I got to meet both of them
what was that like it was like a dream
come true to be honest with you it was
it was it was something that I make a
major impact on myself when I first meet
Michael and then Co V and then magic I
remember my last season plane we went to
Dodger Stadium and magic he I wanted to
sign something for me and he said he
said me basketball jersey sign autograph
we everything everything that he did war
he play it was very special MJ when I
first me angry I basically told her name
man you know where because of you I
almost don't begin to be a baseball
player he was like why and I was like
because I want to be like you anybody
want to be like Mike you don't say and
in then Kobe when I first met coffee man
it was like he it was I was like a kid
when you see the ice cream because he
was expressing you know like like the
way he handled himself and then you you
watch it on the core doing what he do
you know and and and everything related
to Kobe it was very special you know and
I want to take this moment to you know
Vanessa his wife and his kids his family
man you know we praying for your way we
try to keep it together for you I was in
the Dominican when I heard the news I
was my family
and it was it was something that he had
make a major impact worldwide you know
somebody like him his beautiful daughter
Gigi and those other members of
different families that were there where
um you know and something that
definitely all of us are suffering you
know what happened talking to David
Ortiz how are you feeling by the way I
feel great man you know like back to
norm back to my regular doing my regular
thing working now you know being BC you
know I've been all over the place do you
know why you were shot you know I can
really talk much about it because it's
another investigation okay
still by the most important thing is
that everything is going well you know
I'm um I feel good and I'm healthy you
know everything is moving along pretty
well so it's all good have you watched
the video yeah before I did not anymore
no no I'll come
well you know like you said you just
stop watching it
no yeah yeah I mean it's something that
I mean it was like out there plenty of
time for Bennet you know so you don't
wanna you know continue building up that
trauma no yeah you know and he is move
along and you had us worried yep yeah I
just worried yeah yeah things happen and
you just gotta move on
what kind of you know diamonds we got
there you got the ring you got my house
I got four greens at my house so okay
actually they're fine I got one 2018
does that still work with the Red Sox oh
you got one for that I got one what do
you think the appropriate penalty should
have been New York for the answer is
well to be honest with you I don't I
think you know the gang supposed to be
play you know the right way all this
technology you know this thing had been
add to the game I think it's good but at
the same time you know allow you to I
guess do things differently just like it
happens so I know MOV gonna gonna do the
right thing mo B it's very professional
and it's very Emily made sure always
that the fans are certified you know
with their decisions so I think they
already started securing things the
right way yeah it's it's tough because
you want to believe that what you're
seeing is real and then there's a part
of the game that you're trying to get an
edge you're trying to like did you care
if I knew what the pitch was and I could
tell you what the pitch was would you
want them to be honest which you found
hitting scores like
but papi you have players who will tell
you I'd rather not know the pitch and
I'm going I'd like to know if it's a
fastball change give me the picture that
you would have like when you face
somebody like Pedro I have five
different pitches all of them gray all
of them good when you are hearing you
are thinking in your mind what is he
gonna throw me ninety seven or he gonna
throw me 82 what is he gonna throw me at
12 six or you're gonna throw me a
quarter 94 like that is what is going on
in your mind now if I know that he's
gonna throw me breaking ball I'm gonna
slow myself down and boom because I know
what it's coming you don't say in
baseball we are allowed to try to figure
it out when the guys step in when the
guy is making a move to throw this pitch
a lot of guys does that I mean a lot of
pictures they had to work in the
mechanics so much so I say heater we
don't figure out why it's coming now in
the other hand technically the way
things was going on from what we see
that is a whole totally different
subject yes because now you have a
camera that is saying in sickness and
guys are banging something it's it's not
right
how often did you go to the plate trying
to hit a home run 95% of the time 10% of
the time happened did the other 80 80 85
you know like more likely he never
happened I learned that one time I was
having a conversation with Jun Tommy and
I asked him the same question for my
younger days when I wasn't Minnesota and
he told me papi look all I tried to do
is let the ball travel deep and try to
pull my best swing on it doesn't matter
where the ball
go away I know I'm a strong enough to to
be able to hit the ball it was the whole
field to hit the ball so I just want to
let the ball travel deep and go from
there and then that was like that was
when things start making sense to me
we're talking to David Ortiz Big Papi
joining us here who gave you the
nickname how long you you've been called
Big Papi been a while been a while quite
a while the meaning I got to Boston
that was when somebody said because I
I'm I'm terrible with names like I can
remember I can't even remember my own
name in some time and I just puppy
everybody so but it was it was Jerry
Remy who first great red sock Brown yeah
he was the first one who from error he
called me during the game while he was
broadcasting he basically called me beep
up and that was it
you got a Super Bowl commercial man I'm
so excited about this Super Bowl
commercial you know I've been living in
Miami for the past couple of years and
now you had a Super Bowl right here you
know I basically we just filmed this
commercial for Hyundai and we have so
much fun it was a rainy day that way we
have a lot of fun you got John Krasinski
who's on the offices in there Chris
Evans is on there so it's a Boston
themed Hyundai commercial it's all about
Boston man you know I mean try to use
this day their ass and you know wicked
smile you know I never pay attention to
Boston and into that day because you
know like I got a while I play up in
Boston you know I I got related to so
many people like I deal with so many
people everybody in Boston you know was
so great to me I still go back
to Boston and then he just mortal death
ain't there and I love it though if I
close my eyes and you speak I feel like
I'm listening to somebody who's from
Boston you know when you give me that
accent Parker I only know how to browse
a couple of words with a busting ass and
you know wait how about no ma no ma no
mom no
what's great to see you have you acted
in anything else
prior to this commercial I'm all over
the place I have tons of commercial
Indian movies yeah what were you you
remember that movie that they film in
Boston based on that we go goodnight and
or not winning the war serious and then
we end up winning it fever pitch yeah
with Jimmy Fallon yep
and Queen Latifah yep you're in there
yeah I miss that let's see you're such a
good actor I didn't know so
congratulations on the commercial and
the great folks at Hyundai who are
putting on this commercial and I'm glad
you're smilin glad you're healthy
because you know what we need a lot more
of that today
you guys need to smile right for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]